here's something interesting I flew a
drone for the first time over the
weekend Pat and I actually posted it to
my Instagram which is i'm david pakman
on instagram i hope people will follow
me there and uh it was very very
interesting stuff i don't know if you've
had any experience with drones this was
the DJI mavic pro and it's very little i
think it weighs pound and a half or two
it essentially folds up into something
barely larger than a water bottle and it
was a friend of mine got this one I am
super interested in drone technology
after after having fun with this thing
and does it have a camera on it because
I think that's the best part to the
later see the images that you can you
see from I don't even know how many
thousands of feet up in the air maybe
this one can go up to i think it's 1,500
feet it goes 60 miles an hour we flew it
over to a mutual friend's house about a
kilometer and a half away and snap some
pictures of his house I'm going to be
super upfront with you I have no clue
what the legal resolution is going to be
do a lot of this stuff because once it
gets more than 150 feet off the ground
you can't hear it and it's very
difficult to see unless you're looking
for it and you can easily track a car or
a person with this thing I asked a
lawyer friend of mine what's going on
with law around this he says I have no
idea i mean if you call the police and
say there's a drone following me what
can they even do you can't even see it
from over 150 feet up i guess they would
have to try to shoot it down if they're
going to do anything i mean do you have
to register with the FAA now you have to
register it but that's five bucks and
unless you're within five miles of an
airport it's not like you have to report
when you're flying it and questions
about expectation of privacy and it's
endlessly fascinating and I'm super
interested in getting one but I also
recognize if tons of people have these
things and even if they don't the legal
issues are going to be really really
interesting or if companies like Amazon
start using them to ship packages I mean
I guess value Maiden yes indeed also a
picture that did well that I posted to
my Instagram account david hackman i
finally received and by finally I mean
it's all finally all up and running and
the coffee is shipping out both my
progressive wake up call espresso david
pakman show coffee and my freedom of the
press drip david pakman coffee
which you can get at david pakman.com
slash gear i have already dug into the
freedom of press and it is absolutely
fantastic and the reviews are in and
people seem to love it I'm getting
through some prior espresso beans that i
had so i haven't yet opened my espresso
bag people are just absolutely loving
the coffee pad it's surprising because i
know you're an espresso guys right to
see you wait this long i mean that's
kind of telling it's because since I'm
an espresso guy I had a bunch of
espresso already at the time if these
arrived so anyway now that we need to
dig in too much into my coffee
consumption here but david pakman.com
slash gear is where you can get the
coffee and please follow me on Instagram
on Instagram at david pakman